welcome back to New rockstars I'm
Whitney van laningham and look dude I
don't know about you but I'm not
entirely convinced that we can trust
Abomination long term I know what you're
gonna say people who write haikus are
totally reformed Whitney but Charles
Bukowski wrote poems too and that guy
was a lifelong a-hole while I want to
believe that Emil Blonsky is a totally
changed man with zero desire to ever
relive that 2008 night in Harlem I'm not
buying it watsky's seven soul mates
might be able to keep him satisfied for
a little while but like prison yoga life
in human form is gonna get old but today
I'm going to explain why I think Emile
Blonsky will eventually revert back to
Abomination on the outside and within
okay cram junkies and murderinos grab a
chair grab a beer and let's talk some
green Hue crime examine blonsky's appeal
to Jen and compare it to what we saw
back in the Incredible Hulk when Jen
calls Blonsky out for going on a
destructive Rampage in Harlem very much
against government orders he argues that
the super soldier serum given to him by
Thaddeus Thunderbolt Ross made him Hulk
out but that's not exactly true way back
when Emile Blonsky was a highly
decorated soldier he said something to
Ross that tipped his hand as the movie's
villain When Ross comments that with his
military record he should be a colonel
by now glonsky says this now I'm a
fighter
I'll be one for as long as I can
abomination
blonsky's first
super serum he was rare into
earned a big theme around super serum
since the very start of the MCU is that
it amplifies the true nature of a person
good becomes great bad becomes worse so
while Blonsky argues that he was given
an imperfect formula with potentially
personality altering side effects it's
also possible that his actions spoke
more about his character than he'd like
to admit not only did he volunteer for
more serum he was pretty stoked to feel
like a monster You could argue that the
first dose of the serum side effects
caused him to Crave power but like he
said himself he's not turning down a
fight and after the hulk smashes his
bones to powder plotsky does feel
vengeful I don't think that it was all
the serum like he also said he thought
he was going to be the next Captain
bloody America he was power hungry he
wanted to be stronger than the Hulk by
the time he steals Mr Blues Mr Green
formula he's at heat craving like dude
is Jonesing to morph out
I want more
you've seen what he becomes right
wow I need that
he almost
the infusion so bad and I don't think
that that's solely the serum's fault
this dude was in to kick ass at all
costs from day one there are times when
I'm up so late that it Cycles back to
early and I have a hard time sleeping
with Rosy finger Don creeping into my
bedroom it used to be the case that when
that would happen I'd grab a blue blocks
blackout sleep mask but now blue blocks
has become uncharged so I grab a
boncharged sleep mask instead I know it
sounds weird to say I'm bad at sleeping
but I am something super horrifying
about me is that I sleep with my eyes
open but if I'm using boncharge's sleep
mask that doesn't matter it blocks out
100 of incoming light it's very soft and
has adjustable eye cups and an
adjustable strap for the perfect fit it
works for belly's side and back sleepers
okay it's super comfortable and I can
confirm that I can see absolutely
nothing if I were napping this would be
perfect yay now I can see again
boncharge ships worldwide and have other
great products like low blue light bulbs
red light therapy devices and blue light
classes go to boncharge.com new
rockstars use coupon code new rockstars
to save 20 that's
b-o-n-c-h-a-r-g.com new rockstars and
use coupon code new rockstars to save 20
even though Tim Roth delivers an amazing
performance choking up at just the right
moment to get you to feel sorry for him
I'm sorry Emil but I am not falling for
it he's jealous that Bruce is held up as
a hero while he's rotted in prison for
over a decade and I don't believe that
he's over their fight I mean initially
in his conversation with Jen he winces
when mentioning The Hulk and refuses to
differentiate between Bruce and the
other guy this tells me that Blonsky
still subconsciously views his old foe
as a monster first and a man's second
could he possibly not believe Bruce is
reformed because he isn't either also
nowhere in this scene does he actually
promise to keep the Abomination within
him at Bay blotsky tells Jen that she
won't be seeing much of his Abomination
side around and about but not seeing
much of the Abomination isn't the same
thing as not seeing him at all similarly
he tells her that it isn't that he can't
or won't turn into the Abomination he
just chooses not to but what happens
when he inevitably does become
Abomination once more can he control his
thirst for power like Bruce controls his
Rage or will his monstrous Persona get
the best of it when it comes to
blonsky's poetry I'm reminded of a short
Abomination comic Arc from the early
2000s an Incredible Hulk Vol 2 issues 24
and 25 we find Abomination retired from
villainy teaching a creative writing
class apparently he's very well loved by
his numerous students but the second he
smells an opportunity to battle the Hulk
he abandons his healthy outlet and
Newfound career just to make another
attempt at settling the score between
them if he's so full of Vengeance that
he'd abandon his creative writing job
just to fight an old nemesis from years
ago I think that we can expect Emile
Blonsky to eventually ditch the haikus
and choose to revert to his monstrous
form on top of this we have the seven
soul mates while there has been some
speculation that these soul mates he's
referring to are the Thunderbolts
Marvel's anti-hero team of allegedly
reformed villains I don't think that
this is the case there is a quick shot
from the She-Hulk trailer Taylor that
shows seven flower crown women visiting
blonsky's set while I still think that
Abomination is a prime candidate to join
the 2024's Thunderbolts his pen pals are
giving me more Manson family Vibes than
Suicide Squad ones in the comics it is
never a great sign when Abomination
becomes the leader of a group in his
earliest Incarnation during his first
battle with the hull he snatched up as a
living trophy by The Cosmic entity known
as The Stranger skipped to three
publication years later when Thor
finally frees the strangers prisoners
Abomination convinces all of them to
join him in a revolt against their
captor but the goal to form a band of
cosmic pillaging barbarians Thor crushes
those plans but the next we see of
Blonsky he's the first Maid of a space
pirate ship and he's just as brutal I
kid you not the Hulk quote unquote
knocks him out from space all the way
back to her Blonsky then spends several
decades as a Hired Gun obsessed with
destroying the Hulk until he finally is
convinced to put the violence behind him
and live in the sewers here he becomes a
leader once more this time of a faction
of homeless Misfits and mutants this
period of time was when Blonsky was
written at his most virtuous self but
when the police start encroaching on his
territory in search of drug dealers he
becomes bloodthirsty once more and kills
with Reckless abandon drawn to the
surface by the hull he makes his motives
clear he's tired of living in a world
that treats him like a monster when he
has the strength of a God he tried
playing by society's rules of Peace but
he was still persecuted I believe that
while not a one-to-one we could be
seeing a similar story unfold here with
a free blonde ski still facing negative
public scrutiny pushing him and his soul
mates with sensationalist media coverage
until he snaps and returns to his
Abomination ways to be thorough let's
examine the other side there's always
the possibility that he's telling the
truth that even though he can still turn
into Abomination and may even do so from
time to time he'll always keep his cool
going forward obviously Bruce eventually
found scientific therapeutic and
technological ways to keep the other guy
at Bay but Blonsky was always able to
maintain his intelligence and awareness
during his transformation if he's
telling the truth and he really has
changed it could be that prison gave his
smart brain enough time to change his
heart but based on everything we know
about this character from The Incredible
Hulk and the comics I believe that Emil
Blonsky is a fighter through and through
and that he will resume his jealous
grudge against the Hulk's Freedom hero
status and power and personally I would
kill to see a fight between smart Hulk
and the Abomination so far we've only
seen them physically interact while the
Hulk is fully in control but now we've
got these two incredibly intelligent
inconceivably strong dudes with the
ability to Duke it out with a combo of
brains and Brawn Wong might have been a
good sparring partner but the Hulk is
truly on abomination's level and I
refuse to believe that our Lord and
savior Kevin feige would Rob us of a
fight against Mark Ruffalo follow me on
Instagram and Twitter at whitneypuppy
follow me Rockstar subscribe to new
rockstars for more analysis of
everything you love and thanks for
watching bye
[Music]
thank you
[Music]